let's go next to our caller from the
eight one four area code who's calling
today from eight one four hey this is
Evan hey David hey Evan tipica not much
first of all you're my favorite
political commentator on the internet or
like in and ya think you really like
watch me win on the rods royale thank
you yeah so my question was it seems
like the moderators really went after
Bernie last night they made the cost of
attending $1,750 so obviously his the
majority of his base had no way of going
particularly in South South Carolina
right so I'm wondering what you think
about this does you think this concerted
effort from the DNC to suppress Bernie
and go after him actually helps him as
in if you think they were burning
neutral do you think he'd be in a worse
position in the polls because after the
debate CBS his own survey of audiences
asking them who did the best on the
debate Bernie won that which yeah I
Peter it seems like people are missing
he was that was that we had a website
survey or where was that survey I'm not
sure I just saw it on YouTube right
after the debate I just have a thumb now
I didn't click on the video yeah I mean
listen it's conceivable that there's
something to what you're saying that by
sort of going after Bernie they are
helping him because people see that he's
being attacked I guess we'll know after
Super Tuesday right Super Tuesday is
going to be a pretty decisive day there
will be one of three outcomes at Super
Tuesday either Bernie will do so well
that he will have a very clear path to
50% plus one delegates either the the
results will be so split that the most
likely outcome will be nobody gets to
50% plus one but Bernie has a plurality
or Bernie will do so poorly on Super
Tuesday that he won't even be on a path
to a plurality of the delegates I don't
think that last one is likely I think
one of the first two situations is
likely and we'll just have to wait and
see
because we we just have not had enough
most votes cast yet to know what the
effect on bernie support has been so far
from the the corporate media and DNC
opposition to Bernie but we're only like
five days from figuring that out
yeah all right thank you so much
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you and appreciate the kind words
as well one of our sponsors today is VIN
Chara watches giving you 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of inch arrows watches are
made with high-end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but ever even
chera watch ranges from about a hundred
and fifty to three hundred bucks I went
over to their website and picked out the
bellwether and silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people asked me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch